à ce propos le sondage baromètre réalisé
par fiducial aux docks ça indique que
nos concitoyens à 57 % se déclarent
favorables au projet de loi anti
terroriste c'est un sondage réalisé pour
le figaro
angélique bouin les fichiers est
finalement ils sont pas concernés dans
cette finalement est ce que ce n'est pas
le grand oublié de la loi en livrant une
vraie question parce que là on est on
est dans l'idée qu'on doit renvoyer à
l'opinion publique qu'on avance sur le
sujet emmanuel macron n'avait pas le
choix on est dans une telle situation
qu'il faut envoyer des mesures dont ce
projet de loi qui permet de sortir de
l'état d'urgence en rentrant dans la loi
enfin rien faire aurait été
effectivement un vrai souci en même
temps la vraie question effectivement
c'est le renseignement c'est le travail
qui se fait autour de ces fichiers est
sous des gens qui sont soupçonnés d'être
des mouvances c'est la façon dont on ne
sait pas aujourd'hui des radicaliser je
dis rien il y avait un échec des centres
qu'on a essayé d'ouvrir notamment à
tours sur lequel finalement on arrive à
rien donc ces questions là en fait sont
évincés par ce débat effectivement
politique à mon sens n'amène pas très
loin je veux dire prenons un exemple que
faire contre un camion à rien
aujourd'hui le ministre de l'intérieur
gérard collomb nous dit que ça a servi à
déjouer des attentats
c'est pas vrai ce qui a servi à déjouer
des attentats c'est des enquêtes de fond
c'est un artisan sur un balcon cas
perçoit une bombe derrière une vitre et
qui alerte la vérité c'est que les gros
attentats déjoués de ces derniers mois
par les éditions les nations unies par
les assignations à résidence
donc faut se poser c'est vrai question
la vraie question c'est comme cet été
avec les différentes attaques
différentes attaques sentinelle on a
besoin de voir la police et les
militaires dans la rue chez nous en
france est un besoin du coup on se
retrouve dans une situation ils
deviennent des cibles aller dans un pays
comme chez les angles les anglais qui
sont durement frappés
moi j'ai été il ya encore quelques mois
on rentrait dans les musées sans être
fouillés peut-être que ça a changé
depuis les derniers attentats
en attendant il ya beaucoup moins de
présence policière ou militaire en
angleterre qu'ici